the jury has reached a verdict in the
trial of Sam bankman free joining me now
is Fox Business correspondent Kelly o'
Grady Kelly what do we know
tonight good evening to you Laura so we
are getting word that Sam bankman freed
has been found guilty of the charges we
cannot confirm how many charges he has
been found guilty yet of there were
seven counts including uh wire fraud
conspiracy to commit wire fraud as well
as conspiracy to commit moneya
laundering and a number of others but if
convicted on all charges he is facing up
to 110 years in prison now the jury
began deliberating after a month-long
trial at roughly 3:15 today so do the
math they came to the verdict within uh
4 hours just over four hours that is
never a good sign for the defendant I'll
tell you even in the Bernie madeof trial
they took 4 days to come to a verdict
the Elizabeth home trial 7 days now what
happens from here we are expecting of
course for the defendant to file an
appeal uh there is also a March trial
where he faces a number of other counts
and decades more in prison certainly the
fact that he has been found guilty uh
tonight not looking good for that March
trial but I will say I've been in the
courtroom Laura a number of times and I
think really what did it for the jury
was the last thing that they heard uh
from witness testimony with Sam bman
freed taking the stand for multiple days
and he really did a 180 in these types
of Trials it comes down to credibility
especially when you have witnesses his
inner circle testifying against him the
jury had to ask themselves who do you
believe three people who are all saying
we committed fraud we plad guilty and he
told us to do it or someone who got on
the stand an MIT grad and said I can't
possibly remember what happened back
then oh I can't recall that so that
likely uh was the nail in the coffin for
Sam bankman freed in the minds of the
jurors like I said a verdict in roughly
4 hours um they didn't have to have to
spend on this too much Laura we'll bring
you more on those counts when we have
it all right Kelly thank you so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else